години на частку розкладені моїх потреб
втб стеку Європи у п'яний міністр
закордонних праворуч немічений
франк-вальтер штайнмайєр причому even
watch бути травня але у азії конфлікт між
москвою танка рою через битий туре
чорну бомбарду вольник су-24 абу в пару
тисяч головним завданням
врегулюванням конфлікту на сході
україни берлін хочеш і будете протирати
ефективніше 650 з і мікро іншу годину на
тему організації
видали ваще думова тис а скажіть
експерти шкіри
публікую проблем вулиці нікого на daewoo
та депозиті Російської Федерації
у мене такий вираз що за вуста не 40
рокки зараз і підписання ельфійському
ув'язненого акта методичні покличте
заради очок союзу тут і париж не
позиції русі і тут але нічого не
змінилося оленка заповіту він у не
мічені шанс видно в цій діалогу
головне дуги рамеш країни бути членом б
з поважаючи вольфганг ішингер
кілочки посереднику бійся підірву його не
конфлікту на сході України
експерт опинюся в кеші за борги руки
організація вчилася black ой авторитетно
країна
я чума подивимось вона порядок дані без
цей український щур завершуючи наш у топі
і наскільки нам відома на травень нас
правді плану б у заходу
сенаді і по я за низ мінськими
домовленостями успіхи від них пов'язали з
санкціями проти Росії
tomoya точно може сказати ще буду
багатого ладу мінського процесу nike
захід даси покладаючи на день берліні
заповнюють україна не стану розмінною
монету та уссурійському конфліктний
гумкою мін хен і не вашому причин в
Мишу ось ці дві теми затікала не в тому
щоб Росія була конструктивною
партнером для політичного розрізання
сирійському конфлікту la russie en його
артура страхового ти вчених диску nike
сніжка ще до України не меч і навчили в
цьому lbc проти всього наступна уроку